Okay.
We've been talking about these sort of like
four meta issues in American politics for
a while now.
One of those is climate change, climate change.
If we don't deal with it, uh, it, it impacts
everything else that we care about.
If your city's underwater, it's hard to be
an activist for education policy is the way
I like to, uh, have sort of apply a metaphor
or an example to it.
Net neutrality and Internet freedom is another
Meta issue.
We learn about most of what's going on in
the world, um, through the news media and
through the Internet and through a websites
and from news stations that are so impacted
by net neutrality and internet freedom.
So that's another Meta issue that affects
a lot of a, of what we care about.
Our electoral system is a third, the fact
that we have an electoral college and everything
that connects to that, including voter suppression,
voter Id, the way, votes are counted the way
primaries are handled, all of that stuff.
So the electoral system would be like Meta
issue number three.
And then you've got campaign finance, which
rounds out the list.
The way politics is financed in the United
States, a big part of campaign finance is
citizens United.
Now, it's not the only part.
It's not the only reason why we have the system
of campaign finance that we have today, but
it is a big part of it.
And Democratic Congressman Adam Schiff has
now introduced a constitutional amendment
to overturn citizens United Citizens United
is the 2010 supreme court decision that did
away with corporate campaign spending restrictions.
And if this constitutional amendment were
ratified, it would allow limits to be put
back in place by Congress and by states on
the contributions that companies can make.
And it would let states decide if, for example,
they want to make public financing of elections,
the law of the land.
So this is huge.
It's great news.
It's the right thing.
We should support it, but there are caveats.
Caveat number one is this is going nowhere
for as long as Republicans control the Senate
and for as long as Republican a Republican
is in the White House, that's number one.
But it's still good to get this going.
And I support Adam Schiff doing it because
we've been talking about a constitutional
amendment for a long time at the same.
It's really important to understand, and this
is a great opportunity to do it, that there
are many other things we can do to deal with
the money in politics, status quo, which is
a disaster in the United States that are separate
from the repeal of citizens United.
Number one, we can change our voting system
in ways that would be a huge step in the right
direction.
Some of the specifics about how that can be
done, we've talked about on the show already.
The point is that's totally separate from
citizens United and it could lead to significant
improvements in the sort of election status
quo, uh, of the United States of America.
Number two, we could get rid of the electoral
college.
The National Popular Vote Interstate Compact
is about 70% of the way to achieving 270 electoral
votes, which would allow with no change to
the constitution, a de facto national popular
vote.
That's something else we can continue working
on.
Number three, gerrymandering.
Yes, gerrymandering is connected to money
in politics, but gerrymandering is also connected
to many other things, including the census,
which is upcoming in 2020.
Um, and in general, uh, doing redistricting
with a nonpartisan or bipartisan commission,
sometimes employing particular mathematical
algorithms rather than the whimsy of individual
partisan lawmakers.
There's a lot that can be done with gerrymandering
that doesn't require repealing a citizen's
United, dealing with voter suppression tactics.
This includes everything from voter id, limiting,
limiting, early voting, reducing the number
of polling places on and on and on.
We've talked about all of those things.
Yes, a lot of that connects to a citizens
United and how politics is financed.
But we can also accomplish a lot, uh, independently
on that.
But all of this is really to build on fixing
money in politics.
It's not, instead of fixing money in politics,
so we do need to get rid of citizens United.
But it's also really important to understand
that in the nine years since citizens United,
uh, became the law of the land, it has opened
the door to a lot of other incremental changes.
Citizens United in and of itself is not the
change that needs to be undone.
It's a big change that needs to be undone.
But it has opened the door to a lot of little
changes, getting rid of restrictions on what's
called express advocacy, um, allowing electioneering
by more organizations, which in and of itself
led to the creation of many superpacs and
lots of other things.
So, obviously citizens United allowed a lot
of these other things to take place.
But what we need to not forget is that even
if we were to overturn citizens United by
whatever means, it's ultimately overturned
if it ever is.
You still need to undo a lot of that other
stuff that came from the citizens United ruling.
And that's a major uphill battle.
It's worth doing.
It's not impossible, but understand that even
the citizens United repeal is one step of
probably hundreds just in that pillar of the
broader total reforms that we're advocating
for so good for Adam Schiff.
This is the right thing.
We should push for it, we should support it,
but let's not overstate its importance.
And most importantly, let's remember that
there are, you know, like six or seven other
areas that we can be working on right now
simultaneously while we push for getting the
Senate back and getting the White House back,
which will, uh, uh, at least make the path
to repealing citizens United easier.
The Supreme Court that Donald Trump has appointed
two justices to will be an impediment.
Even if Democrats do take over the Senate
and the White House, but that'll be a problem.
There'll be a bridge we crossed when we come
to it.
There are way more things that we can be working
on simultaneously related to fixing elections
in American politics.
Let me know what you think about this.
The David Pakman show Instagram page at
David Pakman show has a post about this.
While you're there, follow me on Instagram
as well at David.Pakman